es sind bürgerkriegsähnliche szenen auch
in der zweiten krawallnacht fans
herrscht chaos auf den straßen
die bevölkerung rebelliert weiter gegen
den wahlbetrug von diktator alexander
lukaschenko protestler skandieren lang
lebe weißrussland regime truppen sollen
die revolution verhindert sie bieten
sich blutige straßenschlachten mit
journalisten und demonstranten
mittlerweile oder sogar schon ein toter
bestätigt das innenministerium behauptet
dass ein molotow cocktail in der hand
des protestes explodierte dinge auf die
kürzesten werden wollte aus angst vor
ihrer verhaftung ergriff
oppositionsführerin svetlana d janowski
ja die flucht bisher gibt es keine spur
von der lukas schenkel stürze rinn
der litauische außenminister schreibt
via twitter über mehrere stunden habe
ich versucht svetlana die ich hier noch
scania zu erreichen
ihr aufenthaltsort ist nicht einmal
ihren mitarbeitern bekannt
ich bin um ihre sicherheit besorgt - die
hauptstadt von weißrussland oder biella
rossi ist das land heute nennt es ist
die zweite nacht in folge wo sich auf
den straßen auf den großen plätzen im
zentrum vor dem präsidentenpalast die
menschen versammeln die erste detonation
sind da doch die menschen versammeln
sich immer wieder neu jeden aufgelöste
demonstration findet hundert meter
weiter statt die leute wollen nicht
aufgeben
min es geht in die zweite nacht in folge
mit angst und stolz neueste meldung
heute soll ein landesweiter streik
beginnen im kampf gegen lukaschenko und
wir haben ihnen gerade schon im beitrag
gesehen peter tiede verfolgt für uns die
proteste in weißrussland aber peter du
stehst jetzt an der landesgrenze zu
litauen warum stehst du da warum ist
keine verbindung in weißrussland möglich
weil gelegt hatte wurde ich bin allen
mitteln kämpft er hat das internet
abgestellt würde ich komplett abgestellt
gestern am boden sogar teilweise
telefonate aus der münchner innenstadt
hinaus lockt also es gibt kaum
kommunikationsmöglichkeiten
wir haben uns heute in der früh ins auto
gesetzt und sind
dreiste würde ich die
oppositionsführerin gerade aufhält
ja sie haben zuvor wenigen minuten
gerade erst erfahren
sie ist in the town und sie ist nicht
einfach raus gereist wird sie war zuerst
mit ihrem anwalt und mit einer
begleiterin bei der zentralen
wahlkommission heimlich offizielle
beschwerde gegen das amtliche
wahlergebnis eingelegt und danach die
ganze gespräch gewesen die man das wohl
feministisch dann in solche tour nennt
und danach war sie dann verschwunden wie
anfang an allein aus meint selbständig
zu leisten aber er wisse nicht wo sie
seit stunden steht erst hat sich ihre
begleiterin dann gemeldet auch mit der
informationen die wissen nicht wo sie
ist
und dann ist sie offensichtlich von
gefolgsleuten außer landes gebracht wo
er zwei kleine kinder einen sohn eine
tochter bei denen sie sein will weil
jemand ist ja im gefängnis und
offensichtlich hat nun ihr bedeutet dass
es sein kann dass die kinder nur mit
einem vater im gefängnis aufwachsen und
man nicht weiß wo die mutter hat sie
dann dafür gesorgt dass sie sicher ins
ausland kommt sie soll sich also in
litauen aufhalten waren lettern
erstens ein demokratischer staat und
zweitens ist nicht weit weg und dann gut
vernetzt auch wird opposition hier in
weißrussland und in welcher gefahr
schwebt die oppositionsführerin ganz
offensichtlich ein sehr guter gefahr
weil man weiß dass helga schenk wirklich
von nichts halt macht er lässt ja auch
wirklich brutal sind das was wir säen
fängt ja nicht nachts nicht als krawall
an sondern ist wirklich wirklich
friedliche protest oder geht die oma da
geht der student auf die auf die straße
man steht einfach auf öffentlichen raum
und klatsch und ab dem zeitpunkt wo
geklatscht wird kommen die schwarz
gekleideten spezialeinheiten machen jagd
auf jeden und auf alles und sowas
brutales habe ich wirklich ganz ganz
selten im leben gesehen und vor allem
nicht so massiv und nach dem was wir
gestern abend und heute morgen gehört
haben hat sich das landesweit abgespielt
wirklich in allen größeren städten gab
es brutale jagd sehen und selbst im
kleinen kreis städten gab es
demonstrationen das hat dieses land
wirklich in 30 jahren noch nicht gesehen
gibt es denn auch gezielte angriffe auf
journalisten
das ist etwas ganz dramatisches also es
häufen sich jetzt die berichte der
chefredakteur zum beispiel von von anni
war von der ältesten zeitung
weißrusslands die heute nur noch online
erscheint auch ein ganz wichtiges blatt
war einigermaßen unabhängig gilt als
verschollen es gibt mehrere journalisten
die als verschollen gelten es gibt auch
verletzte fotografen also es wird
gezielt mit gummi wirklich hart
gummigeschossen auf fotografen
geschossen
zum beispiel wurde gestern abend
niedergestreckt ein fotograf der agentur
getty images mir ist zum glück
weitgehend unverletzt geblieben einfach
weil eine panzerbrücke weil er die
getragen hat es gibt andere leute die
wirklich angeschlossen werden von von
diesen beschossen und es wird gezielt
jagd auf journalisten gemacht man möchte
die bilder und gottes willen nicht in
der welt haben